[Music]
thank you
for the current regime is highly
paranoid and highly impressive so they
passed an anti-terror law for instance
which is very wide uh ranging uh very
sweeping and so many many things now in
Egypt can be considered crimes of
terrorism for them
or false news just simply means anything
that you know contradicts the regime
[Music]
see next year
shut down you know opposition media
outlets and now run an authoritarian
media apparatus right but the one thing
they can't control as easily is
individual social media accounts right
people
[Music]
foreign
leeway in how long they can keep people
in pre-drial detention and then
basically continue to renew those uh
those detentions so people can actually
be in jail for quite a long time without
being uh you know even going to trial
that's one of the many tools of
intimidation that the regime is able to
use
foreign
[Music]
s that they're kind of just taking
people's phones to monitor content to
see what posts people are liking uh what
people are writing on social media or
posting on social media and so it's
really kind of an orwellian situation in
Egypt and it's very unfortunate because
after the 2011 Uprising there was
obviously a lot of Hope and aspiration
for for real Democratic change but that
has all been rolled back and really uh
the environment now is more repressive
than even the the Mubarak era
environment was
[Music]